so before that I had done the pilot
unhung and got fired
why did you get fired
so
not my fault actually on this one so are
the other ones your fault no actually
none of them were damn it but
um I
what's his name he he directed sideways
and he had just won the Oscar Alex
Alexander Payne thank you thank you Ryan
so he knows things he doesn't know con
concentric circles Centric circles
he knows that go ahead yeah that is in
your defense that is more useful to us
than concentric circles it is so why'd
you get fired so so to try to make that
succinct
um this was one of those things and it
just shows the class of HBO actually is
the moral of the end of the story well
uh Sue Nagel she's no longer there I've
never seen a guy picture a show she
didn't take it but anyway go ahead yeah
well I it was one of those auditions
you've probably had these where they say
we've seen everyone in town no one is
right and then you're like okay yeah
exactly boy and there's no problem with
the script of course when they've seen a
thousand actresses who can't make it
work but I do tend to kind of come in
the bottom of the ninth and solve
problems for people
so I did that because they said
actresses just aren't getting the humor
I read the scene and it's a sobbing
divorce scene
and I'm like well
okay so it was set in the midwest thank
God because I gave her a Fargo accent
and I didn't cry huh
so me the crier and so I because then it
was funny
so
and I read with it was the other actor
so it's Alexander Payne and Thomas Jane
Thomas Jane these people that have
interesting names so Thomas Jane reads
with me
and he's a quirky duck right so he's not
like he's kind of improvising which is a
weird thing to do to the person who's
auditioning because I just need to know
what the Rhythm will be and there wasn't
so I get it
fly to Detroit
and we're rehearsing
and Thomas Jane is like he says his line
and then I'm about to say my line and he
says his line again
and then oh
okay and then I go to say my only says
the line again I'm like wait what what's
happening so then he keeps repeating his
line kind of the Stella Adler thing
maybe I'm thinking and then he kind of
starts rolling on the floor
doing yoga or something and I'm like uh
I've never
I'm I'm like uh I'm like an old horror
actress I'm like what do you want you
know all right let's get your pants off
let's get this thing going like I'm
gonna hit my Mark I don't care what you
do right I'm gonna kill this thing I
don't even know that my scene partners
are there because I can't you can't rely
on that you can get fired if you're not
prepared within your own
circles right and so
I don't really know what's happening so
I do what I did in the test
afterwards
Alexander Payne says
oh my God Thomas you're so great to work
with I would so much rather film what
you just did than what we have to film
oh and Kristen on the day no accent
you'll be crying
and he leaves and he just won the Oscar
and I'm like he's wrong but he just won
an Oscar
so
they had me he said no makeup on Kristen
they dyed my hair mousy they put me in
baggy ugly clothes with food on them and
I'm sobbing for 12 hours snots running
down my face I I don't want to be
married to you
and I'm trying to save this one line
where she's like back in high school you
were the star athlete you were this you
were that and now you're just hung so
there was one line right where I could
maybe still keep my job so then it got
and then the producers it would kind of
at the end of the day they went oh good
job Kristen it was very funny
and I'm like wow it's not
it wasn't
and you went home and I went home oh and
I did not get along with the dude Eddie
Eddie James or something he was in the
oceans movies she just didn't get along
he played my husband first person in
ever ever I've never gotten along I get
along with everybody
he hated me and he basically told me
that so yeah he looked me up online and
saw that my dad had guns
and he attacked the [ __ ] out of me about
gun control and I'm like hey I'm a
liberal I got it my dad I loved him he's
dead that was his generation they were
Old West Guns he liked John Wayne okay
so anyway back to the scene right I'm in
tears and I say to him please please can
you let this go we're gonna work
together with playing husband and wife
we're going to be touching each other
tomorrow
bizarre go back to LA and it's picked up
and my manager goes are you excited and
I'm like uh
I'm confused
and then I was fired they got Anne Heche
she did they rewrote it
and she did a completely different
character and seen and it was so much
better but the night that I got fired I
went out to dinner with my husband and
this woman comes over to me
and she says hi I'm Sue negle I'm the
president of HBO and I'm like oh right
because I only met her in the test
so you're not really able to retain
faces in that circumstance and and she
said it wasn't you
and I'm like how did a classy lady I
didn't see her in the restaurant it
never happens I didn't recognize her she
came up to you that's class and she said
the scene just didn't work you didn't
work with him it's not you and I can
send it to you if you want to see it so
you know it's not you watch it I said
I'm I don't want to watch it
foreign